Hey how's it going my name is Peeta
today we're gonna play some games some
special games it's gonna be a good time
let's join this new adventure together
let's go oh boy
try picking stuff up but there's nothing
to oh I'll grab this oh this is cool
hey camera guy catch let that scare you
Brad catch ya [ __ ] this is so cool
like I can drink yeah I can put them on
my nipples
let's get ooh ooh oh look at that look
at that I'm a [ __ ] jug leg oh never
mind I wonder if I actually could juggle
in the game oh [ __ ]
press and hold the tiny button in your
non-dominant hand this is which one is
my non-dominant which one do I touch
myself with this one okay so move the
controller holy [ __ ] I have a gun guys
this is so cool boom [ __ ] well what the
[ __ ] is this am i doing portals what am
i doing
and then I press this button oh my
[ __ ] god I just moved all right so
where do we go that oh we go in here
okay
holy [ __ ] this is so cool yeah that's
right I [ __ ] everything up if I want
chair
hey toilet paper I can wipe my ass in VR
guys this is the great this is a great
moment for Humanity that's right so I
don't know what the [ __ ] is the thing
about the game can we do the game thing
now please we're at an office there's a
laser secure something okay this looks
like it could be it oh look guys there's
a safe down here I found this app god
[ __ ] damn it
I found the locker now what do I do oh
god I'm trying to hold balance but I
can't this is [ __ ] weird oh can I hit
this oh oh this is freaking me out I
don't like it what's in here okay we
need to find the key where the [ __ ] is
the key where's the key
god damn it we're safe okay we got to
find the key somehow maybe it's
underneath the couch where's the [ __ ]
key
I swear to God piece of [ __ ]
ah what the [ __ ] was that oh I am the
best player come here you little [ __ ]
okay we found the key Bruce let's put it
in [ __ ] yes yeah oh I am the best video
player in the world what you want what
do I do with this oh my [ __ ] god oh
my god what it's in there
hello oh hi guys what's crackin this is
an office let's take the elevator
deadly did you should she just say
deadly robots I log deadly robots I like
the music
oh god that's the deadly robot we must
use stealth good thing I'm the stealth
master yes let's go here [ __ ] yeah we're
in what is this a knife oh my god this
awesome can we kill someone with it
a deadly robot excuse me [ __ ] Oh
yeah what's good that's right yeah
what's good I can t bag him
Oh real teabagging VR all these feels
good with his head is actually here let
me get it let me get a better angle in
there here we go oh okay cool so I can
put knives in here okay that's cool
that's useful yeah I'm gonna suck up on
some toilet paper - will automatic cuz
you never know when you need more [ __ ]
yeah I'm gonna get that one and that one
and that one and that one
alright we're good to go oh [ __ ] there's
steadily robots down there this is so
[ __ ] cool
alright I'll throw coffee mug at him
alright here we go this is my one chance
to hit him [ __ ] me
goddammit oh Sh close okay another one
huh oh [ __ ] [ __ ] it doesn't mark alright
die yeah first try I'm P oh okay let's
let's take our knives back I'm in I'm in
guys I'm in I'm the best goddamn
detective this town I've ever known
I don't see any deadly robots oh god
that's right [ __ ] there let's sneak
up on him guys let's get a real [ __ ]
good look
I'll go sneaking alright here we go I'm
gonna Cherie open up his [ __ ] huh
what happened oh [ __ ] oh no what what
does happen what the [ __ ] are you doing
Hey
all right here we go gonna shove this
right up its [ __ ] yeah you're like
that yeah you like that yeah oh oh yeah
oh you like that you're like when I rub
it back and forth oh that's good isn't
it
that's too bad you're dead [ __ ] I can
lift them up that's amazing
hey what you doing buddy all right let's
find the other guy hey I got your friend
that's all
no don't shoot let's go in the closet oh
god he saw me [ __ ] oh god we don't have
a lot of time
come here baby oh god he's coming
suck my dick hole the [ __ ] is that
robot six Korean action yeah get right
in there oh oh oh this is why BR was
made Oh God
hey hey hey take down I don't wanna I
don't wanna I don't wanna I don't wanna
I don't look [ __ ] god damn it god
[ __ ] damn it I find Oh God uh where
the [ __ ] am I
I listen mate now you're not gonna
follow that's Ted I just [ __ ] baby
I'm done it this is like the Kinect but
not a piece of [ __ ]
say hello to my look damn it [ __ ] here
when the [ __ ] what is my goal why am
I here okay a big red button we gotta
press it what you owe
that's it baby y'all ready for this
[ __ ] yeah oh yeah oh so good alright
guys those budget cuts VR is here when
are we gonna see some titties really
really really [ __ ] cool is the kind
of thing like if you have the money buy
it and if you can get it for free hell
yeah so yeah leave it like we enjoyed I
really appreciate it let me know if you
wanted me to check out more games in VR
I'm definitely super pumped for it
thanks to HTC for sending me one of
these and it's always stay awesome
breasts Oh
Mellor armpits can you decide which the
best food Oh
blow it up flowers you want this monster
bad